[Music]
then why don't we get started here so
happy Thursday everybody Welcome to the
data science hangout and hope
everybody's having a great week if we
have never met before I'm Rachel Dempsey
I lead our Pro community and lead up
customer marketing at posit the data
science hangout is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear what's going on in the world of
data across different
Industries and so I like to add if you
are watching this sometime in the future
Maybe on YouTube and we will start to
get some of those past weeks up there
pretty soon um any you want to join us
live you can just use the link below in
the YouTube description to add it to
your calendar and join us in the
conversation but at the data science
hangout we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for
everybody we love to hear from everyone
no matter your years of experience
titles industry or even languages that
you work in so it's totally okay to just
listen in if you want maybe you're doing
some work on the side and we're just in
the background that's okay but there's
also three ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective So for anybody who hasn't
been here before those three ways are
you can jump in by raising your hand on
Zoom you could put questions in the zoom
chat and always feel free to put a
little star next to that question if
it's something you want me to read
instead maybe you're in a coffee shop or
something and then we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and
so we're doing things a little bit
different today and we're ready for it
we've done this a few times here um but
we actually don't have one featured
leader today we are all the featured
leaders today so this will be an open
conversation with all of us and we can
all ask each other questions to the
broader audience um kind of jump in and
share our experience too but I'll get us
going and kind of kick us off on a topic
but if there's something that's top of
mine for you definitely share it into
the chat here
too Lisa I love it yes I'm finally a
featured
leader um but something I've been
thinking a lot about lately is of course
presentations because the posit
conference is next week and I know
there's been a lot of preparation
happening in terms of talks and slides
so I thought that could be a fun
starting point for us um to hear like
what lessons have you all maybe learned
along the way in giving conference talks
or even presentations at your own
company and I'm just curious if anybody
has some tips or things to share with us
I
see some things in the chat about gifts
I was trying to drop in a funny gift
doesn't work could you repeat the
question I came in like halfway through
uh it being asked yeah so I was just
kind of starting off the conversation
with everybody about presentations
because poset conference is top of mind
for me with it happening next week uh
and to just understand if anybody had
any tips or Lessons Learned in giving
conference talks or the way that you do
your slide preparation as well okay
Abigail I might call on you first
because I just read yours first is that
okay um yes I in a coffee shop so tell
me if you can't understand me I can hear
you um okay yeah so look just this whole
approach of like you know look I'm a
nerd I like coding I want to show people
code like that's just never the answer I
mean you think it's gonna be the answer
but really it's like reverse engineering
what is gonna be to my audience you know
and not treating this as like this is an
opportunity for me to talk but treating
this as like what is it that's actually
going to be useful in somebody's
life absolutely that's great um Mike I
see you had your hand raised too I I
didn't notice that before you want to
jump in here
yeah thanks so yeah Abigail's advice is
absolutely spot on um but the we've had
articulation training so this is
articulation is a a consultancy group
who've been working with posit to help
the speakers kind of get ready for posit
com and the advice has been absolutely
fantastic I've I've fundamentally
changed what my slide deck and and
presentation looks like from before I
started um what they got us to think
about is like what is the hook so what
is the thing that you're going to try
and draw people's attention in you know
because we're all dreadfully distracted
by everything um in in the room and so
you want to hook people in and then what
are if you like three
key items that you're going to want them
to remember
later and then once you've got those
things
and and you know you may or may not have
a cult of action at the end um of the
presentation um but once you know what
is your hook so what is the key theme
and then what are the three kind of
things that you want people to remember
afterwards only then kind of flesh out
each of those three and then think about
what is the visuals or the you know cues
code images whatever you want that
support those three
elements you know I I I think like many
people I can of was used to opening up
PowerPoint and jumping in and just W
loads and loads of text and it's really
really hard to then edit that down
whereas if you step away from PowerPoint
or keynote or whatever it is you're
using or or even Cal and just think
about what are you know those things
that I've just articulated
then and I actually I used um a mindmap
uh tool which allows me to think about
you know what are those things and then
explode each of those and go what are
the topics or what things must I
remember to say about
those but then kind of work back from
that and once I've thought that through
then I open up PowerPoint and it it has
as I say it's turned around what I've
done yeah that that's a great Point Mike
I remembered that from last year too and
and I just took like a bunch of sticky
notes I remember sitting down at my
kitchen table and just writing like as
many ideas as I had about the talk and
just putting it all over the table and
then trying to like organize those
thoughts a bit into little groups and
then thinking from then what would the
presentation look like
too hey Amanda I see your hand raised
want to jump
in yeah so um a full disclosure I used
to be an educator so um I have a lot of
experience with uh keeping people
engaged especially when there's a lot
going on you know the the conference is
busy some people are there virtually and
you want them to listen to what you're
saying and focused on you so definitely
as few words as possible on the slide
and something that our now hybrid world
has given us the opportunity to do is
put a code or a link on your first slide
to your slides and your notes so you can
tell tell people hey this is available
to you so you don't need to be
frantically writing notes if you don't
need to everything's in there why don't
we just talk and then keep it very very
simple um and that's going to help
people focus on what you're saying more
when they have that relief like I don't
need to write everything down this is
available to me great points um I'm I
will try and catch up in the chat too
but I see Hest you had your hand raised
as
well yes so this isn't uh Earth
shattering but uh it's easier to
remember and it's more interesting to
listen to when your presentation has a
story so just to remind people when they
think about preparing their presentation
if they can share a story because that
will capture attention and uh people
enjoy it more yeah I'm really enjoying
this um image you put in the chat to
Jake about like examples of a bad slide
and good slide maybe there's some way I
can share that with the YouTube
recording too yeah absolutely I I just
have a really hard time when someone
puts just a wall of text up it's a
little hard to follow so yeah I think
Bolding is a is really helpful too so
not just change a color but make it
bold the other thing was like visual
visuals like
have you know a limited number per slide
you know it's easy to overwhelm the
audience with a Al and things that they
need to look at oh and some text um so
the things that I've done for my slide
Tech at the minute is have like one big
Visual and one small amount of text in
Big
Font repeat and be consistent and how
those things
look and and like consistent
visual design also just helps people
kind of like just go it's okay I don't
need to fres that this is a different
you know animation style or you
know that things are different styles
it's just like you can concentrate on
the actual words I found that the the
big images for a slide really helped me
remember a presentation too like even my
own talk last year about community
building I was thinking like what were
my four main points and in my head I
pictured those four like the big images
on a a slide and then I'm like okay I
can
remember um let's see any other thoughts
in the chat that somebody wants to jump
in and and share here too oh I so I just
got a preview of Laura gast's talk um
and it's going to be awesome it's
talking about all of this um she's
talking about kind of the cognitive
research that like helps you kind of uh
Focus people so I I highly recommend it
that's awesome yeah definitely have to
add that one to the schedule yeah I feel
the anxiety we all have about uh
multiple talks happening at one time
trying to trying to add them
all um one topic or one follow-up
question on the topic of presentations I
was curious for you all when you're
putting together slides for internal
presentations do you ever send that
information out ahead of time like or
with a summary before a meeting or is it
usually in the meeting that's it's the
first time people see it I never know
sometimes like sending something out
ahead of a meeting are people actually
even going to go through it or do you
assume that they they will I would say
yes um ahead of time but usually I feel
like the kind of Storytelling streamline
talk that like you would do at this
conference is very different from the
kind of slide decks I tend to send out
at work or that get sent around at work
the one ones that work they they're
information dens they have a lot of
numbers a lot of tables a lot of charts
like you're intending to like spend time
with it and like read it and stare at
the numbers and understand the report
out of the results of the test whatever
which is very different than this sort
of talk where I think like than like the
posit talk where they're encouraging us
to have minimal stuff on the screen and
and people should to listen to our words
right so I think it's super important
for like information dense Decks that
are kind of half a document to be read
and half to be talked through and Asos
to like this sort of conference where I
think the the decks will be considerably
less information
dense and I guess I'm trying to also
figure out what's the difference then in
presenting a story to people in a
conference and getting them to
understand what you're saying versus
like getting your colleagues to
understand the key story behind the data
too yeah I've been thinking about that
because like I kind of wonder how useful
like we have an internal conference here
for analysts and I kind of was telling
some folks you know maybe something like
articulation Inc coming to us before the
next internal conference would be good
but that's because for that conference
it's a lot of people reporting out of
their area of expertise like it's like
people like teams talking to teams that
don't usually work in them so like a a
giant blast of numbers and data is is
out of context and you kind of need like
a story storytelling would be helpful
whereas
um like if it's your own team you're
just kind of like people already know
what you're kind of heard what you've
been talking about for a couple of
months now you're just showing like well
here's what happened with the a test I
think it can be more information dense
so I think it really depends on the
audience and how familiar they are with
stuff beforehand I I feel like I'm
dominating the last five two minutes so
I
will't no that's it's helpful um Daniel
I saw you had some chats or you had
something in the chat here about
presentations for leadership would you
want to jump in yeah so and I apologize
for the background noise
um I like to keep my slides very light I
like to use lots of images use the five
seon of color and whatnot but when
you're meeting leadership you have a
very short amount of time to convey a
bunch of information so what I will
usually do is take all of the images
from my slide deck and put them into a
sales slick it's usually four or five
pages that it has all of the detail that
you're going to cover in the
presentation for both so when you send
out both now they can see the slide deck
but they can also see all of the detail
that you're going to be providing all
the backup and all of the nited prior to
the meeting so then they come in
prepared and they can ask really good
questions and I it's for me it's been
pretty successful that's a great
Point thank you I um I was putting a
question out into the chat to say like
if there are certain questions that
everybody has and wants to ask everybody
here feel free to put those in there too
I see there's a lot of thoughts here
shared on the the presentation topic but
like a follow-up one on that was I think
from Samir if you want to jump in here
and ask that to everybody yeah thanks
Rachel hi everyone uh Samar here um so I
think like I've been through so many
presentations myself giving them but
every time I give a presentation there's
always those Jitters that I have and I
kind of wanted to hear like out of
curiosity how would like how do you
personally deal with those like
presentation Jitters that you get right
before it or even during it it looks
like George has some thoughts for this
or is that a separate question George no
I do have some thoughts okay cool yeah
um I I took uh some training actually
when I worked at HealthNet giving a
presentation to our exx and what was
helpful was really the power poses that
they had do which you're like so like
weird when you start doing them yeah
Mark something like that like the power
you know you get in your chair you get
all like make your body big um you do
there's like different ones I'm I'm sure
many of you heard of those right and do
them but for me that helps a lot kind of
get rid of jitters there's something
like it's almost like doing yoga in a
way because like you're stretching your
body you're breathing getting the blood
flowing um but a from that the other
thing that kind of calms my Jitters is
rehearsing like rehearsing it to death
um so even if it's just a five minute
speech or a 15 20 minute speech I
rehearse it and refine it to where I
don't need a lot of
words um but if I need if I have the
extra time I you know I certainly can
fill it but uh yeah I think rehearsing
it and subtracting
from from the things I'm saying and only
providing what's needed is kind of like
how I
feel more confident going into
it absolutely I always remember that one
and and I I've been using lately what
you said Ted to kind of shift your um is
it to shift your nervousness to
excitement
yep yeah I mean it's like one of if you
think of it as nervousness that
disconnects you from the audience but if
you think of it as excitement that's
like you know more fuel for you to
connect yeah no I I definitely used that
one um last week I was giving a ma of
honor speech and I was thinking of
everything I learned from articulation
and putting that into the ma of honor
speech too and trying
to shift the nervousness into excitement
so that another thing is I think it's
natural to feel nervous I think
everybody feels nervous so you know if
you don't then you know that's possibly
a different sign um but the other thing
is that if you have practiced right then
as you're getting up to do the the
actual performance as it were remember
back that you know before you did all
that practice things were a lot
worse right so you've come a long way
since that first first time you even
thought of doing this presentation till
now so if you've done the practice and
you've got that far you're good to go
definitely H Deep shy I see your hands
raised this is um a trick that's helped
me cuz I read it somewhere that if
you're chewing gum right before your
pres big presentation it kind of tricks
your brain that because you're chewing
something you're having lunch like
nothing must be wrong you're just like
eating like normal and and maybe it's
placebo effect maybe it's real but it
has helped me every time so I carry a
tissue paper right before put like put
it in the pocket real quick before going
on the stage but that's actually helped
my Jitters a lot and maybe it's just
like takes all your nervous energy to
like chewing and like your jaw hurts
later but it's helped me a little
bit love it yeah and thank you Alan for
the uh encouragement in the chat here
yes everybody is going to do great let's
get off of the nervousness conversation
because we're all everybody's going to
crush it it's going to be awesome um but
I saw Luke you had a question about
Cordo in the chat you want to jump in I
think it is about if people are building
slides in Cordo oh maybe we can't hear
you but the qu luk question was curious
how many presenters are building slides
in Cordo I see deep shest hand
raised I see you unmuted does that mean
you are yeah sorry I I am slow to find
reactions no worries just curious is it
working now yep we can hear you now well
that's great
okay I know personally I've used it a
few times and I've enjoyed it um but
when it came to something I had to have
a
um animation in I had to go back to
PowerPoint because I'm not quite that
advanced yet but um I've also been lucky
I'm in the I go to the
um the Southern California our user
group and Emil happens to be there and
does his slide he's done his slide craft
posts as well as um he's done that
presentation on slide craft a few times
and they're really
good definitely if if you wouldn't mind
sharing those in the chat that would be
awesome too and Deepa I know you've
given a great talk on Cordo as well if
we want to grab that one and put it in
in the chat too um okay we can Shi gears
on data visualizations but I'm really
excited to go back and reread some of
these comments here in the chat when I
have all of my brain power to dedicate
to reading the chat too um but another
question that I was C I'm going in a
completely different direction here um
but I know something that's come up a
lot
in past Hangouts is around onboarding
and it's usually talked about in more of
like a negative way of like companies
doing a bad job of on bond boarding and
I was just curious to learn from you all
like what are some of your favorite
successful onboarding stories and what
made it so great um because I think
there's probably something that we all
could learn from from hearing that those
stories and Jared I'll I'll kick it off
with you because I see you said
something right away here can you guys
hear me okay yep I can hear you sorry
yeah no I think for me it's just been
every role I've taken if I kind of been
thrown in the deep end having that
Lifeline of a mentor somebody who's been
there and can kind of help steer the
waters has
always put me in a position to get a lot
further a lot faster like infinitely
much much so like I've never felt like I
was always having to go at it alone and
then you just kind of gradually
transition from you know new to to
semi-experienced or season that then you
can pass that on to the next person kind
of coming in and I I haven't had the
opportunity to do that as much as I
would like but but yeah that's I think
my big my big takeaway definitely thank
you for sharing I I'm seeing a few
comments here in the chat and Melissa
you said you have one to offer do you
want to jump in yeah so um I think one
of my favorite personal onboarding
experiences um my boss handed me this
sheet of paper and he was like okay you
know tell me your preferred style of
being approached tell me what your pet
peeves are you know all of like tell me
what you would have wanted to tell your
last boss that ticked you off right um
so having those kind of candid
conversations with people is really
important and then when I got to pelaton
one of the things that our Enterprise
data team does is creates a user manual
So within somebody's you know first
couple weeks they go okay here's what
makes me tick here's you know all these
things about me and how to approach me
what what motivates me what am I afraid
of what am I really trying to do here um
and and we love it we we still use that
practice today and it really helps
people kind of break out of their shell
and make uh connections when we've got
such a large team that's like you know
40 plus people it really uh you know
kind of breaks the ice there so that's a
great
practice that's really interesting so
it's like a it's a template that you
give to everybody or you know it really
shouldn't be it's really like we we have
we keep them archived so everybody can
access them on our Google drive but we
want people to you know kind of make it
their own and have fun with it and um
you know whatever is going to help us
understand their personality and how
they
work well thank
you Mark I think I saw something you
said around 30 60 90 check-ins maybe do
you want to jump in I was on mute um
yeah I mean the job I me currently um
when I first joined it was pretty clear
like hey like already when you join
here's the plan for 30 60 90 days um you
know we have like a project for you
coming in we expect like
um this amount of progress and we'll
check in um you know and that'll help
you get both get your feet wet but then
also provide like sort of this clear
Direction um uh rather than you know
just
ambiguous uh like sit in on meetings and
like pitch in where you can is very uh
you you'll get up to the speed at at
some point with that method but it's
just a lot quicker I feel like with that
like plan ahead of time from the hiring
manager Absol
absolutely um Amanda sorry I missed your
hand was raised
before oh yeah um I was just going to
say a lot of times in my experience when
you're on boarding people seem to still
be like they're like worried you're not
up to date on the skills but they've
just vetted you on your skills and so
the best thing you can do for somebody
is the specifics like this is how we
connect with our server and this is how
you you know the specifics to your area
you know we have this platform here that
requires this funky code those are the
things that frustrate people the most
and so those are if you're on boarding
somebody those are the little details
that they really need um and then the
other thing is that we're doing in my
current position is we have uh markdowns
notebooks whatever for uh all of our
meetings that have from all the way from
like here's how you access the
spreadsheet we put it in every single
one so somebody on boarding has the
opportunity to
just go through this stack of notebooks
or whatever um and see how people have
done things in the past um and that a
lot of times those little details are
actually in
there um something I want to get better
about when I'm helping on board somebody
or just doing an intro call with them is
just reminding myself that they're being
thrown so much
information right now and like they're
not going to retain every single piece
of information so if I could be the
person to actually like tell them a
story about a customer or something that
they're able to
remember rather than like just throwing
more facts at them and giving them more
time to like come ask about the facts
but to at least like understand the
culture by the story that I'm
telling um let's see Hands raay I saw
Marcos I think yours one up first you
want to jump in yeah it's completely I'm
sorry I did Miss I'm try multitasking
here so I missed who was speaking last
but I completely agree with the idea
like when we on board new data
scientists you know there's I kind of
assume that they know python they know
pandas they know like how to do how to
be a data scientist but they don't know
yeah all the quirks of where our data is
hidden like how the weird paret files
that we not weird but the the unique
parquet files that we use to store our
data and how it's organ how how it's
organized by by date tables so we have
some very formal SQL training that
introduces people to like like our kind
of Enterprise you know uh ter SQL type
tables but then I have written some
Jupiter notebooks that are very much Le
I mean they don't they're very lead by
the nose they just basically show and so
something they can refer back to later
like how do I load this kind of data oh
here it is I did it in this notebook
right and so it kind of leads them
through step by step like loading some
data making a toy model like using some
of the the the quirky tools that we
built internally and I do think that is
the the most important thing at least
for new data people is yeah we know they
can like understand transend and they
can do explor dat analysis but like what
are the quirks of our system and how can
we best help um help a new high
understand those
quirks absolutely Adrian I saw your hand
was raised hi yeah um so a couple of
comments right that um it depends on the
size of the organization you know
typically if you're like an Enterprise
um there's there's an onboarding team
right you really don't have to worry
about that I mean earlier um there was
common made on markdown files right um
um yes definitely documentation right to
be able to onboard um those team members
but what I found more important is being
onboarded even to the culture of the um
of the organization I know um in my
current role well my when I when I
joined my current um I I guess uh
Enterprise that I'm with right now it
was so huge and one of the comments that
I asked um um during my um um um
interviews is will I will there be
learning opportunities to grow right the
path to like and um the the interviewer
just went yeah and then he just kept on
going and I really didn't get why he
joked like that and he just anyways I
Now understand why because oh my gosh
there's so much enablement in my
organization it's just stupid every week
there's just so much and um so now I get
it had I had a mentor that could have
said oh yeah there's more than enough of
so I think having or pairing a a new
hire with a a seasoned employee a mentor
helps tremendously and to onboarding to
the culture because all the technical
stuff that's documentation we're all
we're all smart here you could read you
know you could move forward to it if
there's a hiccup the mentor will be able
to support you there so I think that's
my big take on on onboard definitely a
mentor Absolutely I'll have to go
through and watch the recording again
and take what's in the chat but I can
see Mentor being like the one of those
that's right at the top of the list here
um Jake I see your hand raised and then
Jordan I I'll call on you after this too
yeah we have a four-week onboarding at
my rwork and it's like drinking from a
fire host it's where does data come from
data privacy it's uh the tools we use
use a variety of tools um so I think
something that's been really helpful is
I added a analytics workflow wrapup and
so it's just like hey these nuggets that
we mentioned that you might have missed
are like very important and so it just
kind of is a something that I think they
can reference for a while after
onboarding that's kind of how I present
it to them is you know here's a slide
deck but also like keep it keep it handy
because there's a lot of little things
that would make your life a lot easier
so after they've gone through the data
comes from and all that other stuff we
just do this wrap up to connect the dots
that seems to be help
folks thank
you and uh Jordan you want to jump in
here next sure yeah and I think in the
same vein as that idea of having a
mentor like having that seasoned veteran
who will probably someone within your
teamwork Department who will help you
get through those sort of things is also
getting some experience and
understanding outside of your team
specifically when you have I've seen lot
of really brilliant programmers get into
a new industry and not really know what
the data that they're looking at is or
kind of where it's come from or why it
matters so I think like having a good
understanding of of like the positions
that you're probably helping or
departments that you're probably helping
with um with their data is just getting
to know what are they doing what are the
things that are important important to
them um and then also it helps with
understanding why the terminology
they're using doesn't make any sense to
you or why specific data terminology to
you just doesn't make any sense to them
and just just helping bridge that sort
of Gap and really getting a better
better overall experience about what
this company is doing what your goals
are and how you can think about um some
stuff that isn't kind of directly in
front of you as
well absolutely I am okay maybe we'll
we'll shift yours a little bit here I
see Zoe you had asked a question in the
chat do you want to just ask it live and
then I can call in some people who asked
who put answers there too thank you so
um we've had a couple of job interviews
out so I work in the NHS in England and
we've had quite a number of them so it's
taken a lot of brain power to get
through all the application forms um but
what I would like to do is just check
with people what kind of experiences
that you've had that are really good to
use so I've mentioned about tests we've
all kind of agreed from ourselves that
test didn't really work out and does it
really show if somebody's very good so
it's just having that idea we are
restricted by some of the things we have
to do like we must always ask the same
question of every single candidate
because it's part of the public sector
approach that we have and we'll have the
same amount of time pretty much unless
people have some extra requirements but
it was just ideas from people it will
all be online as well so you know maybe
things like questions because sometimes
they can be quite long can go into to
the um chat for example uh we're going
to give them in advance actually we're
going to go against the grain in our
industry and send them out but other
things like that those little titbits
that people have enjoyed or
appreciated I love that everybody's
jumping in on this thread here Libby do
you want to jump in
first um sure I don't remember what I
said oh okay I said that I really enjoy
it when I can tell that the interviews
that I'm in are FOC on me as a person
and who I am and if I'm going to fit and
if I'm a good human being versus my
skills because you can get anybody in
there with the skills um making me feel
like who I am matters to the role and
that my soft skills are also valued has
been really important for me because I'm
a technical person who has great soft
skills
so hearing that those are valued um is
pretty pretty great uh and recently I
had a really good interview where I had
sent questions ahead of time I think I
had sent four questions I do that a lot
I send things ahead of time as much as
possible to help people be prepared for
things um and then the interviewer just
took my questions and let them frame the
interview like I will just go through
and answer your questions and you can
answer back to me with you
know counter points or whatever from
your experience um and that worked
really really well and made me feel
really welcome that's great and um toyan
I I see you had some ideas too yeah I've
been through um some processes recently
for the US federal government so similar
constraints about how um fluid you can
be uh but there is a a pilot that
they're doing called the SME QA process
and so it's subject matter expert driven
um and as part of that process they
allow you to do uh kind of a use case
and provide a coding sample um which is
a great way to kind of highlight your
skills because normally it's like you
said being in the public sector your
very constrained and don't get to kind
of show your individuality and skill set
um but I do think there's a fine line
between asking individuals to
demonstrate their skills and at some
point um making them feel like they're
doing free work in order to prove
themselves and so it's definitely a fine
balance definitely um okay I see a lot
of people jumping in here with some
ideas too
so if you want to unmute and add some
more context to what you added there
I'll keep my eyes out I see Jake Mike
and Abigail you all added some
thoughts okay Abigail you put another
thought let's have you read read yours
too oh the one I just said so yeah so I
I asked I I data scientists there are
some standard questions that I ask but
you try to give everybody the same
questions and the answers I get from
people with equivalent resumes range
from having no idea so like they give me
the right answer and then they're like
okay but there's actually more
complicated answer I'm like nope youve
got it 100% we're done with that
question so like yeah I mean it's just
it's really important for me to do
technical questions because like you see
somebody with a resume and it's really
Incredible or you see somebody with
resume you're like this isn't that good
but then like they just know the answer
so we do the sopt too but like I I gotta
ask
questions thank you all for for sharing
your thoughts here in the chat it's it's
nice to uh get to see them organized on
a thread here too I kind of like this
this format here in the chat um bolar I
see you asked a question
about um starting a user group and would
love to have you jump in here and ask
that hello
hi um well I've been listening to y'all
for a little bit and just while I do
other work um yeah so I am at slan
University I'm a graduate student in the
ecology and evolutionary biology
Department
and um the group has been for around for
a little bit but it had a coid Hiatus
and now we've rebranded and we call
ourselves twerk and it's very New
Orleans to Lans who enjoy art
coding and we're just I'm just one of
the kind of collaborators organizers and
trying to you know uh Workshop ideas and
like how to get people involved uh kind
of I guess what are the best like
onboarding strategies of like hey
bringing people in like getting them
interested or comfortable some folks
come and they're like uh a lot of
graduate students have a crash course in
r or like a rough relationship with r
when they don't have like a a more
coding background uh I'm one of those uh
but now you know this is I'm I'm trying
to get more involved than get better at
it so just wanting to hear from you all
awesome well thank you for being one of
those Community organizers um I see Greg
has some thoughts here you want to jump
in
Greg yeah absolutely so I I can uh speak
to you I lead I work for Charles Schwab
and I lead the data science at Schwab
User Group um our last meeting we're
actually trying to schedule something
with with Rachel and pait pretty soon
for our next meeting but our last
meeting I think we had a little over 200
230 or so uh users from across Schwab uh
come in and and and hang out but um I'll
just Echo like it hasn't always been
that way right we started out really
small uh we started out as an R User
Group Pur just purely R uh moved to R
and python then moved to data science
and when we were the r User Group it was
basically the same five people uh who
were just getting together monthly and
presenting back and forth to each other
and I came in with zero R knowledge too
right I was SAS user SQL user at the
time and wanting to learn R and so uh
everything was really cool to me right I
mean they were showing me like basics of
deer thought it was awesome um you know
but uh we started small I'd say a couple
things that we've always tried to
emphasize right is that uh all levels of
skills and ability are welcome so we've
got some folks who come in and bring
neural networks and self self-learning
Maps and just like really complicated
Financial topics that you know we've got
phds presenting back to us um you know
the the specifics of which are probably
over a lot of people's heads um but
everyone finds it really interesting but
we also encourage the person who like
just learned uh how to do something cool
in in you know in r in Deer in Python
whatever it is right if you just learned
the basics um we had somebody who was
you know I was just posting about
something I was pretty proud of we had a
user who figured out how to connect to
our big data environment via python
rather than using the console like those
are just small wins so like if you
include everyone I think is really good
chance um plus giving everyone a chance
to present too there's there's so many
folks out there that the way that they
really learn and really expand is by
pushing themselves to present even if
it's something that they just learned
themselves that that might be you know
on the more basic end so um that's
really helped and and I remember five
years ago when we started this uh the r
in Python Community here was just
so fractured and so small and you really
had to like I mean it was basically
Google and stack Overflow uh to to
figure out your answers it still is to
some extent but now we have you know 200
something people who come together at
least once a month plus teams channels
and stuff and we're we're all helping
each other and deploying packages that
we can all share and things like that so
but just encourage you to keep it going
thank you thank you that's amazing to
hear also how how much the group has
grown um but also congrats on deploying
your first shiny app to shiny app Sayo I
just saw that in the chat too
yeah i' I've only deployed them
internally for work before this was like
my first like personal app and I was
expecting like Linux and package
dependency errors and all kinds of
things but man shiny absu IA is done in
like five
minutes um on the community topic too I
feel like something helpful to just add
or say too is I know like we do have a a
tendency to like celebrate as things get
to be like really large groups and
that's amazing too when we have a ton of
people engaged but also if even if you
have a small group of people coming
together once a month that's awesome too
um so it doesn't always have to be like
a a huge group too like we have a uh
data science Community Builder coffee
hour that we do once a month and there's
about maybe seven of us that will join
pretty frequently and we always have
great conversations there too um and
that's been something I have to remind
myself like it doesn't have to be a huge
group to be a successful Community
too um but I say that because if anybody
is organizing communities and wants to
be a part of that group um let me know
in the chat here and I'll I'll send a
note over to you
too um but Ted I know you were kind of
tagged on that question in the chat do
you want to jump in here with any other
thoughts too um I think part of it and
I'll talk about this at posit conf is
really making it easy for new members to
contribute and I think there's there's a
lot of different models you can do that
and I'll I'll talk about what we do in
the Portland R User Group which is um
everyone kind of brings in their
problems and it kind of normalizes that
you're having problems that problems are
okay and that you don't need to know
everything so that's I you know it's one
of those things I feel like as a
community organizer you have to have a
light touch with answering questions
like try to let the community answer it
because it empowers people absolutely I
was um trying to type in the the chat as
well we have I have this data science
Community Builder course site I've been
building um but I want to keep making
this better with thoughts from you all
and especially all the uh research and
work you've been doing Ted I feel like
we should incorporate that into it too
but I um I've just shared it in the the
chat yeah for sure definitely and the
community Builder talk is or coffee hour
is super fun it's kind so just my
plug than thank you um let's see George
I see you had a question about data
governance want to jump in here oh yeah
thanks yeah data governance um yeah
specifically about apis if anyone has
any experience with that because we're I
mean we're generally just rolling out
like a data governance um effort at our
company and U I'm in charge with my
domain but considering that we might
start sharing data with um others like
citizen data scientists through not only
traditional like reports in our system
but also through
apis that's something that I've never
really touched before as just wonder if
anyone has experience with best
practices or any
suggestions or any potential pitfalls
that I'm not maybe looking at right
now hey George this is Adrian um feel I
mean that's a loaded question because
there's so much involved with governance
um if you like I mean feel free to reach
out to me and I could talk to you
specifically about what we done with
several Enterprise clients because we've
set up I I've personally set up um well
personally had a team with um setting up
um Enterprise uh data cataloges which
includes obviously um governance but um
I'll put my email in the um chat and we
could feel free to reach out to me
afterwards oh cool yeah I appreciate
that any other thoughts maybe it would
help if I I see Marlene I see Marlene
unmuted so she has some thoughts to
share too oh I always have thoughts
whether they're sharable is a whole
another question right um so just so I'm
clear is your question more about the
howto or more of the logistics of
sharing and or permissions
based it's
maybe not not so much the logistics but
it's like okay because I think we're
concerned and that specifically I'm in
HR so I have like HR data um
privacy demographics a lot of a lot of
sensitive data and making that available
through API sounds pretty exciting to a
lot of Citizen data scientists so
they're like yes we can finally get some
data do our own analyses I want to
support that but then I'm also like
that's a lot of data to put out there
and yeah we can do security so
logistically I'm not really all that
concerned but maybe more like from
a expectations level or level setting or
culture standpoint um like how do you
roll that out to
people anyone yeah that's kind of where
I'm that's kind of what I'm looking at
right now maybe more of that I'll throw
my email in the chat as well um so the
last data set that I worked with with
apis was around food safety data which
is super sensitive that's basically like
Hippa dat for all of us that's what it
is for the agricultural World um and so
they are very sensitive about who gets
to see what and who gets access and
pushing and pulling of sensive
information um so if you want we can
chat about that if you're at posit CL
then we chat about it there or we can
connect on a zoom call or email whatever
floats your Bo
yeah cool I will be there so yeah we
send me your info and we we'll meet up
okay Jake I see you had a question about
mentors want to jump in here oh yeah
just sometimes I get really in the weeds
of some n issue and I just really wish
someone could just explain to me what
I'm missing um and it seems to be out of
scope for some of the places it's not
out of scope but you know I'll put on
stack of a Flo and it'll just sit for a
month or um you know and I kind of when
I fix it by end of day and I can see in
my mind like where I don't know I just
wish I had someone I could tap on their
shoulder and say what's going on here
how do I you get this thing
working like I've done a lot of meta
programming is like reading in code as
the data I don't know it's just I find
myself in these deep Dives and then just
get
stuck I bet there's somebody that you
can find here to to be that person with
you let's see I see there is a lot of um
responses to Jake on here on this
question um does anybody want to jump
in I just clapped instead of raising my
hand because I don't know how reactions
work
um I have been doing something recently
that has been super super helpful Jake
Jake which is just having working
sessions in fact I have one later today
with a friend um I have them weekly just
getting on one-on-one with somebody for
an hour or 90 minutes and working on
stuff and there's it's so helpful to
just be able to talk something through
with somebody and be like I'm trying to
do this and this isn't working and
sometimes somebody will say oh have you
heard of this package and I've never
heard of it before um so even if they're
not a mentor peer mentoring has been
really valuable for me so I would
encourage people yeah it's not always
somebody who has 10 years of experience
over me sometimes it's somebody who has
less experience than I do who's like oh
have you thought of this super basic
solution and maybe I was being too
complicated in my
head
yeah that's
great um and I see a lot of people have
mentioned the r for data science slack
Community too and that's a great place
to go join if you aren't in there
already um and thank you sap toishi for
putting the link in there to join I'll
reshare it in the chat
too um but I see some hands raised uh
Amanda do you want to jump
in um just really quickly I wanted to
agree completely with what liby just
said because uh especially during the
early pandemic co-working was like
awesome just because I learned so much
from people who were outside of my field
they were just friends across the
country and we would just be co-working
just working and then you can shoot a
question out I wonder about this or
whatever it also helps keep you
motivated but I wanted to it's funny I
wanted to Echo something Libby has said
recently outside of this chat um that
instead of necessarily thinking about oh
I need a mentor for this or I need uh
you know this type of person uh focusing
more on just building friends like
making friends in the community that you
can then just text um and it's really
really difficult to do so sometimes
especially because I know I'm an
introvert but um just having making more
friends that you can text in that way is
such a silly way to think of it but it
it can really help definitely and I know
I'll give a shout out here for Libby's
lightning talk at the posit conference
on making data friends
too yeah everybody feel free to plug
your um posit conference talks in the
chat too and share the links to them
because I would love to see how many
people here are are giving talks
too um Zoe I see your hands raised jump
in thanks it's kind of um echoing really
what people have said in the chat and
also Amanda in answer to Jake Jake's
question um I'm part of the nhsr
community and we have a slack group and
so it's part of that you know that you
have a community when other people
answer your questions for you and even
when I ask I get people answering and so
my mentoring that I've had has been from
whoever answers sometimes and although I
don't know people specifically and I
think it does hit that introversion
level we chat a lot through text but
I've never actually spoken to these
necessarily people face to face but I
know that sometimes if I put a question
out certain people will latch on to
these ones because they're so good at
that particular area and also what's
really great is when somebody else says
I can't solve it either this is a big
problem because you said like when you
put it on stack Overflow and then nobody
answers for months and you're like is
that just because I haven't worded it or
is everybody really this lost it's
really heartening to have a couple of
people go yeah this just doesn't
work what what's happening and then at
least you've kind of commiserated
together and you're not alone anymore so
the mentoring has never really been
onetoone but as you say if you find
friends then you can go up to people and
say can you help me with this
particularly particularly if it kind of
Strays into more career Focus as opposed
to problem focused you can then trust
people because you've kind of tested
their technical knowledge as much as
anything and that you know that they're
there for you when you're really
struggling with stuff so yeah go about
it a different way I think maybe just
like be part of a community just
listening sometimes helps well you know
when you we call them lurkers I suppose
in slack that's fine that's great people
are really taking a lot away from the
slack groups I love that point Zoe it's
just helpful sometimes to know somebody
else can't do it either
right um I wanted to Circle back for a
second to George's question before
because Alan I I see you shared some
other thoughts in the chat is it okay if
I kind of pull you in here to share that
um yeah I think um my thoughts were sort
of regardless of the sort of like roll
out method the way you make that kind of
data available I think being sort of a
facilitator or enabler kind of as long
as it takes is really important so that
you set up really clear expectations
about like what is this data good for
what does it support well versus what
does it not support well um and that way
you can sort of be riding along helping
people think about like in your case
compliance issues or or those kinds of
things in particular um and it's a whole
lot easier and and we found this over
the course of trying to sort of course
correct some some big long kind of
multi-year projects it's a whole lot
easier to do that at the beginning than
than later so it's really exciting to
roll stuff out and also it's really
really helpful and important to to sort
of like everybody look around the table
and you go okay wait let's let's do this
slowly let's do this really carefully um
but it's a real balance of of like
feeling success on the on the part of
your team and and and your your mission
and setting up your stakeholders for
longer term kind of success and
stability and
stuff thanks so much Alan um I know we
are getting to the end of our hour here
so I wanted to see if there were any
questions I perhaps missed from the chat
here that you wanted to ask everybody
feel free to raise your
hand but I love just getting to scroll
through the chat as we're having the
conversation too and just see some of
the things that people are celebrating
too um which is why I asked before we
leave what are some things that
everybody's proud of this past week it's
always a fun way to kind of learn a
little bit more about
people this way like Marlene I saw you
just breed a new goal in lifting like I
just scrolled past that in the chat I
see about shiny apps being deployed um
so always love to to hear those things
in the chat too any other questions oh
people started journaling okay I my
thing I'm proud of is that I did my made
of honor speech last weekend and
successfully got up there and didn't
didn't cry or get too emotional through
it which is okay I made my way through
it what was your final wedding
attendance count for the summer I know
you were going to lots of weddings I oh
we still have two more but it was eight
but we had three last
weekend oh my gosh three in one weekend
they were great
though let's see um also I on what
people are proud of I see Mike pointing
out to his YouTube video I just watched
that video Mike it was amazing so highly
recommend everybody checking it out
anybody have anything else they want to
share thanks that was Shameless
promo wait I don't see the YouTube video
Mike's a rockstar nobody knew that yet
oh there it is I see it so as Ted but he
keeps it very
quiet P we need some YouTube videos
there too oh uh I guess
Cascade
nice well thank you all so much for
joining today and hanging out with us
thanks for kind of bearing with us all
too as we figure out how to do these
without a featured leader and having us
all join in the conversation I thought
that was fun today thank you all have a
great rest of the day and see you either
virtually for posit comom or maybe in
person next week
too
bye everybody aw it's great to hang out
see y'all later bye
bye